what
advice let's put on your wise
visionary hat what advice do you have
for young people today
you've um you've dedicated your book
actually to
your kids to your family what advice
would you give to them
what advice would you give to young
people today thinking about their career
thinking about life
of how to live a successful life how to
live a good life
yes yes i have three stunts and in fact
to them i have uh i have tried not to
give too much advice
so uh even though i've tried to kind of
not give advice maybe
indirectly it has been some impact uh my
oldest one is doing biophysics for
example and the the second one is doing
machine learning and the third one is
doing uh theoretical computer science so
there are
there are these facets of interest which
which are not too far from my area but i
have not tried to
to impact them in in that way but and
they have followed their own interests
and i think
that's the advice i would give to any
young person follow your own interests
and let it that take you wherever it
takes you
and this i did in my own case that
i was trying to study economics and
electrical engineering
when i started at mit and you know i
discovered that
i'm more passionate about math and
physics and at that time i didn't think
math and physics would make a good
career
and so i was kind of hesitant to go in
that direction but i did because i kind
of felt that that's what i'm
driven to do so i didn't i don't regret
it i'm i'm lucky in the sense that you
know society supports people like me who
are doing you know these abstract stuff
which
which may or may not be experimentally
verified even let it apply to the
daily technology in our lifetimes i'm
lucky i'm doing that and i feel that
uh if people follow their interest they
will find a niche that
they're good at and this coincidence of
hopefully their interests and
and abilities are kind of aligned
at least some extent to be able to drive
them to something which is successful
and not to be driven by things like you
know this doesn't make a good career or
this doesn't do that
and my parents expect that or what about
this and i think
ultimately you have to live with
yourself and you only have one life and
it's short very short i can tell you i'm
getting yes
i'm getting there so i know it's short
so you really want not to
not to not to do things that you don't
want to do so i think
follow your interest my strongest advice
to young people yeah it's scary when
your interest doesn't directly map to a
career of the past or of today
so you're almost anticipating future
careers that could be created
is scary but
yeah there's something to that
especially when the interest and the
ability align
you'll pay you'll pave a path that will
find a way to make money
especially in this society in the in in
the capitalistic united states society
it feels like
um ability and passion paves the way
yes at the very least you can sell funny
t-shirts
yes
you